hey I've got some really really funny
stuff to show you guys I appear faces
similar to mine appear in two different
places that have been sent to me by
members of the audience let's start
first with this image sent to me by a
viewer named Jonas this is a picture of
someone interviewing Jean tot the later
f1 Ferrari boss during the 1973 African
rally and if you're not if you're
listening to this on the radio or
podcast check out the YouTube clip for
this story
the interviewer different haircut and a
slightly different nose that guy looks a
lot like a slightly older version of me
doesn't he yeah do you have any proof to
show that you weren't at the African
rally in 1973 well I wasn't born in 1973
okay I think that counts as sort of
evidence but this really does look a lot
like me it's it's bizarre but this is
nothing compared to what I'm going to
show you next this was sent to me on
Twitter by user John Mayer this is a
screenshot from the new video game
Friday the 13th the game okay there is a
I don't know the story of this game but
there is a character there that is being
strangled that looks a hell of a lot
like knee pad everything from the nose
to the eyes to the ears yeah even sort
of to the hair this looks a lot like me
doesn't it you have to wonder if hatreds
are the ones making this game that's
what I want to mention as well as we're
looking at this image in detail I don't
even know who I would contact I don't
know who makes this game but if somebody
wants to do a little bit of research and
try to get someone from the company that
makes this game to comment on that
picture and see like it is it I have
it's not it's not an ego thing where I
think clearly those people are watching
the show and they made me into a
character how did how was that face
developed because it looks exactly like
me yeah I mean this other picture that
you have those are we hammers in a rally
I mean that's that's something but yeah
this one you got a suspect there's
something going on there so anyway after
you look at it if you can try to get in
touch with someone who can give us a
statement about what what the hell is
going on as Donald Trump likes to say I
would love to know more about it and my
girlfriend is
kind of freaked out about her she said
that's really disturbing because it
really looks like you're getting choked
and I'm really worried about this and
that and just really it's not a good
image for ya
people are being distressed by this are
you gonna have nightmares over this well
I didn't last night okay but you know
that doesn't that doesn't tell us to too
much so anyway check this out if this is
clearly a visual thing if you've only
been listening please check it out